In today’s video, we’ll be discussing
the military achievements of an outstanding
cast of characters: a Finnish officer who
fought the Red Army on skis; an American Green
Beret who led dangerous covert missions from
Iran to Vietnam; and the only Waffen SS soldier
to be buried at the Arlington military cemetery
in Virginia.
What is truly unique, though, is that all
these personas were played by just one, singular
person: a natural-born soldier who often ended
up on the losing side -- captured, betrayed,
exiled -- but never defeated.
He would rise from the ashes of war to continue
his personal struggle against his sworn enemies.
This is the story of Lauri Torni, aka Larry
Thorne: The Phoenix Soldier.
Son of Finland
[Note: this quote should appear on screen,
against a simple background, but not read
aloud]
“And through the bitter cold with opened
eyes
You’ll find the strength to fight and stand
upright”
- Born in Winter, J and M Duplantier
Lauri Torni was born on May 25, 1919, in Viipuri,
a town on the Karelian isthmus just north
of Petrograd.
Lauri completed his studies, excelling mainly
in sports: skiing and boxing, among others.
As he came of age, Lauri joined the national
reserve of the Finnish Army.
Following the partitioning of Poland by Germany
and the Soviets in September of 1939, the
Soviet Union hoped to push its borders farther
west by capturing the Karelian Isthmus and
securing Leningrad, formerly Petrograd, from
a German attack.
The Soviets had also set their sights on several
islands in the Gulf of Finland, and on the
Hanko naval base.
When Finland refused to grant such an annexation,
Joseph Stalin ordered the invasion.
Thus, a few months after Lauri’s 20th Birthday,
on November 30, 1939, the Soviet Union invaded
Finland.
It was the beginning of the Russo-Finnish
War, also known as The Winter War.
The Finnish armed forces were led by Marshall
Carl Gustav Emil Mannerheim, a former czarist
officer.
Severely outnumbered and outgunned, the Finns
managed to put up one hell of a fight against
the Red Army – a huge opponent, but one
that was ill-equipped and poorly managed after
Stalin had executed dozens of his top Generals
during the Great Purge of 1937.
The Finnish Army, by contrast, was a small,
flexible unit that had perfected the art of
winter warfare and defensive tactics, exacting
a huge toll on invaders.
At the beginning of the war, young Lauri was
a junior sergeant in charge of food supplies.
Lauri couldn’t have felt at ease with this
post -- he clearly understood how a constant
supply of nourishment was vital for the morale
of his fellow troops, but he thought he was
capable of much more than supply line management.
One night, as the temperature plummeted to
minus-42 Celsius, Lauri silently slid out
of his camp.
Completely unseen and unheard by his own sentinels,
Sergeant Torni walked to a Soviet outpost,
captured a Russian soldier, and marched him
back to the Finnish camp.
The effects on his soldiers’ morale were
galvanising.
Lauri’s superiors realised that this 20-year
old NCO had a talent for light-infantry missions
and assigned him his first special task.
Lauri was put in command of an anti-tank patrol:
basically, it was people fighting on foot,
or on skis, whose mission was to attack Soviet
tanks and destroy them.
Yeah, that sounds easy!
But against any logical bet, Lauri and his
squad did manage to blow up quite a few tanks,
and still lived to tell the story.
Lauri and his Fins distinguished themselves
particularly at the Siege of East Lemetti
pocket, in late February, 1940.
Here, the Finns encircled and wiped out a
strong Red Army contingent, capturing 71 tanks,
206 trucks, and 12 armoured cars.
Lauri was put on a special officer’s course,
becoming a second lieutenant in March.
As a first assignment, he was put in charge
of a company of ethnic Swede soldiers.
They did not speak Finnish; he did not speak
Swedish.
But with the use of clear hand gestures and
the common language of ‘let’s blow up
the invaders,’ the young officer and his
troops got along splendidly.
On a broader stage, though, the war was not
going well for Finland.
Despite having bloodied the nose of the Soviet
Bear, the disadvantage in terms of manpower,
artillery, and tanks was starting to take
its inevitable toll.
Already by February, the Soviets had breached
the Finns’ main defensive line on the Southern
end of the front, the Mannerheim line.
Once they broke through, they were able to
occupy Karelia, and threaten Lauri’s hometown,
Viipuri.
From the 3rd through the 11th of March 1940,
heavy fighting took place around the Karelian
capital, while a Finnish delegation in Moscow
sought to establish terms for a ceasefire.
The Moscow Peace Treaty was eventually signed
at 2 a.m. on March 13.
Finland had to cede 10% of its territory and
12% of its population to the Soviet Union,
including Karelia and Viipuri.
It had been a pyrrhic victory for the Red
Army, which suffered 167,000 KIA and MIA,
vs 26,000 on the Finnish side.
But it had been a victory nonetheless, one
that Lauri Torni would never forget, and never
forgive.
Soviet Enemy Number One
At the end of the conflict, Lauri was awarded
the Medals of Independence, 1st and 2nd Class,
which became the first in a long series of
decorations.
But such accolades could not compensate for
the humiliation of losing one tenth of his
country to the invaders - including his hometown!
Lauri was described both by friends and army
superiors as quiet, pleasant, and courteous.
He was a well-liked young man with whom it
was easy to get along.
But this mostly mild-mannered man had found
a powerful vocation in fighting against a
stronger opponent -- either in direct, or
indirect, service to Finland.
That is why, in the late Spring of 1941, when
Finland was a neutral country deep in the
background of WWII, Lauri Torni decided to
rise from his country’s defeat and head
back to battle.
This need for retribution drove him to travel
to Germany in secret and join a newly constituted
Waffen-SS Battalion, the Freiwilligen Nordost.
It was not uncommon for citizens of neutral,
occupied, or even Allied countries to volunteer
for SS formations, either out of sympathy
for the Nazi cause, hatred of Bolshevism,
or both.
As part of the Freiwilligen Nordost, Torni
received intensive training which honed his
natural skill set -- performing special operations
deep inside enemy territory.
On June 22, 1941, Axis forces invaded the
Soviet Union.
This was the start of Operation Barbarossa.
Finland joined the invasion, not as a formal
member of the Axis, but as a co-belligerent
country.
The Finnish objective was simply to recapture
the territories lost in the Treaty of Moscow,
rather than expand their living space eastward
into new land.
This conflict became known as The Continuation
War, and was again masterminded by Field Marshall
Mannerheim.
The commander asked for Berlin to return the
many Finnish volunteers who had joined the
Waffen-SS to replenish the Army ranks, with
Lauri Torni chief among them.
At the start of 1942, second Lieutenant Torni
was again put in charge of a light infantry
patrol deployed in Karelia – it was payback
time!
His unit was part of the forces that drove
the Soviets away from the isthmus and captured
the main garrison of Petrozavodsk.
From there, Torni continued to push northward
to reach the White Sea-Baltic Canal, then
called ‘Stalin Canal’.
[Note: see this map for the locations mentioned
above]
Lauri’s advance was halted on March 23,
1942.
While on a ski reconnaissance mission, Lauri
stepped over a landmine and was severely wounded.
While recovering in the hospital, Torni received
a promotion to lieutenant and an order to
stay put for several weeks… which he totally
ignored.
With fragments of shrapnel still embedded
into his body, Torni escaped from the military
hospital to re-join his old unit.
Throughout 1943, Lauri led and trained several
units in charge of reconnaissance and sabotage
missions deep behind enemy lines.
An exceptionally fit man, he expected his
recruits to match his levels of strength,
stamina, resilience, and skill in close quarters
combat, especially with the puukko -- the
traditional Finnish knife.
His company became known as the Osasto Torni,
or the Torni detachment.
Its symbol was a capital ‘T’ set against
the backdrop of yellow lighting.
Some of Torni’s best-documented exploits
took place in the summer of 1944, when the
Red Army launched a counterattack to retake
the Karelian isthmus.
On June 9 -- three days after D-Day, a couple
thousand miles away -- his Division was at
risk of once again being engulfed by the Soviets.
Lieutenant Torni and his unit managed to break
a Soviet encirclement manoeuvre, inflicting
heavy casualties on the enemy.
Two weeks later, Lauri personally performed
an incursion behind enemy lines, during which
he acquired vital intelligence on the Soviet
strategy – intelligence which helped his
commanders hold off the counterattack in Karelia.
On the 5th and 6th of July, the Torni detachment
was instructed to hold the crucial Ilomansti
crossroads at all costs.
They were reduced to less than 100 men after
the beginning of the Soviet offensive, and
they were about to face two regiments of the
Red Army, a total of 4000 enemy soldiers.
Against all military logic, Lauri split his
men into even smaller units.
Sure, they may have been weaker, but they
were also highly mobile.
By shuttling back and forth between them,
Lauri was able to direct a series of counter
attacks against the incoming Soviets, which
were convinced they were facing a much larger
force.
Torni’s company inflicted hundreds of losses
on the Red Army, halting their advance and
allowing for the bulk of the Finnish forces
to retreat and regroup.
It was a tactical masterpiece that achieved
an important strategic result.
But Lauri did not have time to celebrate,
as, once again, he stepped onto a Soviet mine.
While convalescing, Lauri learned that he
had been made a Knight of the Cross of Mannerheim,
the highest military decoration in the Finnish
armed forces.
It is estimated that a total of 600,000 Finns
served in the Continuation War, but only 191
of them received such high military honour.
The following month, he was promoted to Captain.
At the same time, the Soviets had bestowed
on Lauri an even higher accolade.
Propaganda radio broadcasts had issued a bounty
on his head, dead or alive.
The Soviets were willing to pay three million
Finnish Marks, which corresponds to more than
half a million US dollars in today’s money.
It’s a small fortune, especially during
wartime … yet no one dared to collect the
reward.
Lauri and his men continued the fight in Karelia,
but their Commander-in-Chief, Marshal and
now-President Mannerheim, was coming to terms
with a harsh reality.
The fight could not go on forever against
the Red steamroller, especially now that Germany
and its allies were losing ground.
On August 25, 1944, the Finnish government
initiated secret talks with Moscow, which
led to the signing of an armistice on September
19th.
The conditions, while ensuring the survival
of the nation, were extremely harsh: Finland
had to cede back 10 percent of its territory,
including Karelia and Viipuri.
Helsinki also had to pay war reparations to
Moscow, equivalent to almost four and a half
billion US dollars in today’s money.
As if that wasn’t enough, Mannerheim was
forced to demobilize most of his army … and
to expel any remaining Wehrmacht units from
Finnish territory.
This became known as the Lapland War … one
in which Lauri did not take part, as he had
been demobilized.
Once again, Lauri Torni wasn’t prepared
to yield amidst the wreckage of another unfair
defeat.
Like the mythical phoenix rising from its
own ashes, he was eager to continue the fight
against the Soviets, whose peace treaty he
did not trust.
Alongside other demobbed troops, Lauri fled
to Hamburg on a U-Boat to resume special operations,
training in a Waffen-SS facility in Mecklenburg,
along the Baltic Coast.
Here, Lauri perfected his approach to asymmetric
warfare, including sabotage techniques, explosives
handling, and deep reconnaissance tactics.
Unfortunately for Torni, the programme was
halted after a few weeks of training because
the Red Army was making its way towards Berlin.
The Wehrmacht was in desperate need of combat-ready
troops, and so Captain Torni was drafted:
he was tasked with leading a Naval Infantry
company, deployed east of Berlin.
Facing once more the invader of his Homeland,
Torni fought valiantly against the incoming
enemies.
But once again, his tactical victories could
not overcome the Soviet’s overwhelming numerical
superiority.
Facing inevitable capture by the Soviets – which
would have meant almost certain death – Torni
instead sought to turn himself in as prisoner
to a British unit which had landed in a nearby
airfield.
His bet paid off, and the Brits did not kill
him on sight.
He was sent instead to a PoW camp in Belgium,
then transferred to Lubeck, Germany.
Life as a British prisoner was surely better
than living as an inmate at a Gulag, but rumours
started spreading that the Western Allies
were transferring some of their PoWs to the
Soviets.
Torni was not going to risk that.
He partnered with a fellow Finn, Solmu Korpela,
and escaped from the camp in July of 1945.
The circumstances of how they did it are not
clear … what is documented is that they
posed as former prisoners of the Wehrmacht
to hitch a ride from a British Army Captain!
Eventually they reached Copenhagen and secured
travel visas from the Finnish consulate.
Lauri Torni had emerged from the ruins of
the Reich and was finally heading home.
But what he received was not
a hero’s welcome.
A Wanted Man
When Lauri returned to Finland in August of
1945, he was almost immediately prosecuted
for treason by the Valpo, the Finnish State
Police.
Technically, they were not wrong.
Torni had escaped to Hamburg and joined the
Wehrmacht during the Lapland War … in other
words, he had defected to the enemy!
The situation was complicated by Finland’s
delicate position between the end of WWII
and the start of the Cold War.
While the Red Army could have invaded yet
again – as it had done with almost all Eastern
Europe – Stalin actually preferred a less
aggressive approach.
He demanded instead that Finland remain a
neutral country, but under a strong Soviet
influence.
It was a shrewd strategic move, as it would
prevent NATO from deploying future troops
along the Soviet-Finnish frontier, one of
the longest sections of the Soviet Union’s
borders.
Moscow’s influence extended to the appointment
of ministers and officials aligned to the
Communist Party – and one of them was the
chief of the Valpo.
Anyway, in August of 1945, Torni had been
arrested for treason, and was placed on a
train headed to a high security prison.
Lauri did not wait for the term to begin;
he simply jumped off the train during a stop.
For the next few months, Lauri reunited with
his beloved parents and his sister Kaija,
who had been forcibly relocated from Viipuri
to Helsinki.
Here, he worked at an electrical supply firm
and generally lived in the open … he enjoyed
the simple pleasures of life as a free, innocent
man!
However, after a co-worker reported him to
the Valpo, the former officer was apprehended
once more.
A trial in October of 1946 sentenced him to
six years in prison for high treason.
Once again, the only way out of that sticky
situation was to … well, to just leave.
Torni certainly was no stranger to evasions,
so in the spring of 1947, he simply walked
out of jail, thanks to a false ID card smuggled
by a friend.
His life as a fugitive did not last long,
though, as Valpo had an ace up their sleeve.
The police spread the false rumour that he
was wanted for theft -- a blemish on his upright
reputation that Torni could not tolerate.
Willing to clear his record, Lauri handed
himself over voluntarily and returned behind
bars at Turku State Prison.
But it wasn't long before the restless Captain
was ready to attempt another escape.
While generally a quiet man, Lauri could make
a quite genial and cultured companion.
He made friends with the organist in service
at the prison Church.
While serving as his assistant, he identified
a poorly secured window in the chapel, from
which he believed he could escape with a classic
tactic: a rope made of bed sheets, tied to
an iron hook.
But on the night of the escape, a guard discovered
him and took aim with his rifle, ready to
end this indomitable soldier’s career.
Luckily, the gun malfunctioned, and Torni
was apprehended without serious incident.
By the end of the decade, the Soviet’s grip
on the Finnish Government had loosened enough
for President Paasikivi to issue a pardon
for Torni.
Unfortunately, the pardon involved his being
stripped of his rank.
His name was removed from official war records,
too.
This was October 6, 1950.
Lauri felt betrayed.
He wasn’t sure he had anything else to offer
to his own country, so in 1949, he decided
to emigrate, crossing the border into Sweden.
Here, he started a new life … as a lumberjack!
[Note to Simon: the following two lines are
a quote from the famous ‘Lumberjack Song’
by Monty Python, also linked below.
Feel free to remove!]
Yes, he'd be a lumberjack, and be okay.
He’d sleep all night and work all day,
He started dating a girl from Stockholm, Marja
Kops, the first and only real love of his
life.
The two got engaged on January 1, 1950 and
had even set a date for their wedding.
The two had agreed that Lauri would wear his
old Captain’s uniform for the wedding photo
shoot, so the girl travelled to Finland to
collect it.
But fate threw a spanner in the works.
Lauri had previously applied for a visa to
travel to Venezuela under the alias of Ema
Mbrsky.
His intention was to join a community of Finnish
expats in the Americas and start a new life.
After months of waiting, the visa had finally
arrived.
Unfortunately, this offered only a very limited
time window for Lauri to leave Sweden.
Torni … was torn.
Okay, that was lame, but Lauri was, indeed,
torn between his new love and the opportunity
to start a new life away from Europe.
In the end, he opted to leave, before Marja
could return.
Lauri got in touch and promised her he would
be back, but their connection waned over the
years.
Eventually, Marja moved to Las Palmas to marry
a Spanish man.
Down in South America, Lauri landed in Caracas
in March of 1950, taking on odd jobs around
the local Finnish community to make ends meet.
Among these jobs, Lauri would work as a babysitter
for his compatriots.
And that’s comedy gold, right there, Hollywood!
A former Waffen-SS Captain and Special Forces
operator looking after young children?
Send that screenplay to all the major executives.
Beyond babysitting, a job more suited to Lauri
was as a sailor on merchant ships, sailing
to the US.
The Finn had since long set his sights on
moving to the States, but the status of his
visa did not allow him to step off the boat
onto dry land.
But a man like Torni would not let a little
bit of paperwork get in his way.
By now an escape artist on par with the Great
Houdini, Lauri simply jumped overboard off
the coast of Louisiana and swam safely to
New Orleans.
From there, Lauri made his way to New York,
where he settled in Harlem, resuming his routine
of odd jobs.
By 1951, Lauri had been apprehended by FBI
agents: he was an illegal immigrant, after
all, and it was only a matter of time before
he would be kicked out of the country.
Luckily, in New York, Torni had become friends
with one Paavo Fleming.
This gentleman was the President of an association
of Finnish Veterans and Soldiers in the States,
and he had immediately recognised the great
potential that Lauri could offer to the US
Armed Forces.
Fleming had brought Lauri’s case to the
attention of retired General William ‘Wild
Bill’ Donovan, a key figure within the OSS
and, later, the CIA.
Now an attorney, Donovan agreed to represent
Torni and was able to secure him a permit
to remain in the US.
Not only that, but he interceded for him to
be enrolled in the US Army.
This is when Lauri Torni reemerged as Larry
Allan Thorne, a legend of the Green Berets.
All the Wars He Came Across
In January of 1954, former Captain Torni started
basic training at Fort Dix, New Jersey, as
Private Thorne.
He must have felt like a real Finn out of
water: he was 34, while the average age of
the soldiers there was 19; he had the inclination
to lead, but he also had to re-train as a
low-ranking soldier; his English was not really
up to scratch, but he did manage to communicate
at least in part with a blend of hand gestures
and shouted profanities.
After completing basic training, he attended
two specialisation courses.
First, there was the Mountain and Arid Cold
Weather Survival Course, which must have felt
like any other Tuesday to him.
There was also the paratrooper course at Fort
Benning, Georgia, which earned him a HALO
certificate.
[Caption: HALO = High Altitude Low Opening]
In 1957, Larry was serving in Bavaria, as
a member of the 11th Airborne Division.
He had performed well in the US Military,
climbing to the rank of 1st Lieutenant.
However, following several months of relative
quiet, he got into serious trouble.
In December of 1958, Thorne was involved in
a pub brawl with some locals, a fistfight
which ended in his throwing several Bavarian
patrons through a plate glass window.
Larry was arrested and court-martialled.
He seriously risked his own dismissal from
the Army, but luck was on his side -- investigators
found that some of the Germans involved in
the brawl had a criminal record, and at least
two of them were wanted by the police.
At Thorne's court-martial in October 1959,
he was found not guilty.
Thorne could return to his duties, but he
preferred to accept a transfer instead, to
the 10th Group of the Special Forces - the
Green Berets - based in Bad Tölz, Germany.
It was with this team that in July 1962, Lauri
took part in one of his best-known missions.
His unit was tasked with retrieving the wreckage
of an Otter reconnaissance plane.
The aircraft had crashed over the Zagros mountains
in Iran, after a secret mission to gather
intel on Larry Thorne’s old nemesis, the
Soviet Union.
Two previous crews of German mountaineer troops
had failed to locate the Otter, which contained
information too sensitive to be left unattended
on a mountain top.
Under the leadership of Captain Schandler,
Larry and a dozen of Green Berets climbed
the unforgiving terrain of the Zagros range
and succeeded in reaching the wreckage.
They retrieved all the classified intel, as
well as the bodies of the airmen who had died
in the crash.
Along the way, Larry and friends even found
time to provide medical aid to isolated communities
on the mountains.
In early 1963, Lieutenant Thorne was assigned
a mission in South Vietnam.
As a military advisor, his job was to work
with the South Vietnamese special forces,
which he led in several airborne missions.
On one such assignment, Thorne, his Sergeant,
and 10 South Vietnamese militiamen were ambushed
by 120 Viet Congs.
Larry’s ‘Dirty Dozen’ soundly defeated
the guerrillas, and he was awarded with a
Bronze Star.
After this first tour in Vietnam, the now-Captain
Thorne returned to Fort Benning for more advanced
training, after which he was ordered to a
second tour in Vietnam, during the spring
and summer 1965.
Thorne was working at the 5th Special Forces
Group headquarters at Nha Trang, as an intelligence
officer.
It was mainly a quiet job, but surprisingly,
he liked it and was soon recognized as the
leader of Nha Trang's intelligence operations.
In late June, the base came under attack from
the Vietcong, but the guerrillas did not achieve
the intended surprise and were swiftly repelled.
This was thanks to Thorne’s intelligence
work, which had enabled
“the prompt response of defence elements”,
as stated by his Commanding officer in an
after action report.
It was also thanks to this success that Larry
was assigned to lead Operation Shining Brass
in September.
This was a secret infiltration of reconnaissance
elements into Laos, a formally neutral country.
On October 18, 1965, Larry Thorne boarded
a helicopter with South Vietnamese operatives.
A photo taken that day depicts him as he gets
to the chopper.
This was the last photo ever taken of Captain
Lauri Torni, reborn in the west as Captain
Larry Thorne.
The objective of the mission was to pinpoint
the location of a Communist troop encampment.
From that perspective, Larry had scored another
success: his team did locate the enemy base,
and the US dropped 95 tons of bombs on it
two weeks later.
However, during the flight itself, mission
control lost all contact with Thorne’s helicopter,
and he and his comrades were declared Missing
in Action.
Exactly one year later, on October 19, 1966,
they were all declared Killed in Action – although
neither their bodies, nor the helicopter,
were ever located during the remaining years
of the Vietnam conflict.
.
Had he actually died in a helicopter crashed?
Had he been captured by the Vietcong, or by
the North Vietnamese Army?
Had he resurfaced again, in another country,
with another name, ready to fight another
war?
It took more than 30 years to solve the mystery.
In 1999, Thorne’s remains were found 25
miles south of Da Nang by a joint Finnish-US
Task Force.
He was repatriated to America.
[Note: Location of Da Nang at this link]
Formally identified in 2003, his remains were
buried on June 26th, 2003, at Arlington National
Cemetery, section 60, tombstone 8136.
He was buried alongside the remaining South
Vietnam Air Force casualties from his final
mission.
Remembering Lauri Torni
In his 47 years of life, Lauri Torni had fought
in three different wars, on behalf of three
completely different countries, all of which
bestowed upon him praise for his valour.
He could proudly wear 17 military decorations,
including the Mannherheim Cross, the Iron
Cross, a Distinguished Flying Cross, and a
Bronze Star.
To this day, US Special Forces have an award
named after him.
A former comrade from the Vietnam War, Robin
Moore, took inspiration from Torni for the
character of Sven Kornie in his book ‘The
Green Berets’.
This was later turned into a movie, where
the Kornie character would be interpreted
by ‘The Duke’ himself, John Wayne.
And in 2014, Lauri was celebrated by metal
band Sabaton, in their song ‘Soldier of
Three Armies.’
If you want to know more about the crazy life
of this character, I can recommend the books
‘Born a Soldier’ by Mike Cleverley and
‘Soldier Under Three Flags’ by Henry A.
Gill.
Of course, not everybody agrees on his hero
status: Finnish authors Juha Pohjonen and
Oula Silvennoinen in their book ‘Unknown
Lauri Torni’ suggest that, at the end of
WWII, the Finn had joined a Nazi resistance
movement with the purpose of carrying out
a National Socialist coup in Finland.
The book is available only in Finnish, but
we’ll leave a link to the eBook in the description
below, in case you speak the language.
Controversy aside, I hope you enjoyed today’s
adventurous tale of the Phoenix Soldier.
As a follow up, let me ask you, which protagonist
of the Winter War would you like us to cover?